i also lost my voice um you know to this
next story we're gonna
you know i'm just gonna be honest with
you honestly i understand if you want me
to you know uh quarantine a little bit
what happened to your voice i lost my
voice while here i'm gonna show you
is i i was lying about my whereabouts
over the last couple of days i was
actually at the chain smokers concert in
the hamptons which is now being flagged
for uh corona and governor cuomo is
saying that he's gonna arrest the
promoter which is my guy tony tickets
and uh and it was in the hamptons and it
was a drive-in and because it was a
driving thing i was supposed to just
stay in my car
but then i climbed up through the
sunroof and i and i unhooked people out
of the car seat and we started dancing
on my roof
i mean dude look at this look at this
dude
i mean in the mikey muffin chops he was
recording in the hamptons a lot
uh the kids got some wild stories i mean
i don't know if it's true or if the kid
just got a christy d
imagination no i think it's true but i
mean my muffin shop says stories a while
but he was out in the hamptons yeah he
said his dad has no nerve endings yeah
he said his dad i don't know he said his
dad [ __ ]
used to you know jump out of planes and
and kill terrorists
we gotta get his dad on the podcast we
gotta get him out and yeah i mean the
kid
but muffin you were um you were in the
hamptons
they just are acting like the pandemic
isn't there right
yeah all my clients all my clients out
there like why are you quarantining are
you okay
i'm like it's a national thing are you
watching the news
yeah they just they don't care they're
just they've permanently moved out there
and they're just [ __ ] partying and
doing blow and it's just what it is out
there
yeah it's completely what it is but my
whole thing is like governor cuomo
saying now that he's gonna
he's gonna uh wants to you know put the
promoter in jail
and that this can have serious
consequences and i'm like hey bubba's if
you're gonna if if the protests
so what does coronavirus only get inside
you if you're doing fun things but if
you're doing protesting then the
coronavirus isn't real
that the prop it's starting to get a
little shaky for me now
when i can understand if they had this
concert inside i could understand that
that's a problem but they did it outside
most people have mass i understand
they're not socially distant neither are
protesters
so um you can't have it both ways
anymore it's
if it's for corona stuff you can't have
it both ways and i also feel the chain
smokers have nothing to do with this
they were told by their agent
you're doing a promotion you're doing a
charity show for whatever
here's the thing they start playing the
music they're they're not responsible
for crowd control they don't even you
know they have nothing to do with this
but they're getting the blame so i think
if governor cuomo does anything
and steps in on this he's flexing his
power and he needs to be removed from
the
governor he needs to he needs to [ __ ]
step down yeah you heard it here on
weapon first we're calling for a coup
of the governor of new york we want a
clue to happen he needs to be
replaced removed cancelled enough's
enough the guy's got nipple rings
something's off i don't know what kind
of sex dungeons he's going to after
hours
but i'm not comfortable with it with my
governor doing that when v
when vanatiya hears the word coo she
goes
that's her word she goes for a good coup
a good
toppling but i think manatee is starting
to get
the upper west is starting to come out
because she's like
okay guys i posted a photo of brianna
taylor yesterday
um what's what are what's going on now
you guys are [ __ ] with my parking
because there was a protest in the upper
west yesterday
it's been a couple months because she's
totally with the cause
but the [ __ ] doesn't want her she does
not want her [ __ ]
parking interrupted well she needs it's
the thing is with v specifically it's
hard with the pro
if the protesters come down their block
and start messing with the cars her
car is not going to make it because
she's got a hooptie holy [ __ ]
so that thing's going to disintegrate
when it gets hit with
i mean because they try to kick that
down one window the whole car is gonna
fall apart
we're gonna get me a new car because
that car looks like it was rescued from
a junkyard
yeah that car looked yeah like like it's
just like it's on some kind of show
i think v what kind of car is that from
what yeah it's a piece of [ __ ]
it's a piece of [ __ ] but it still runs
it's a 95 taurus
wow 95 toys and that's been in your
family since 95 bought brand new
no no no they just we got it for me and
my brothers to share
okay one of my family members gave it to
us like a few years ago
v is the best but that car definitely
looks like look at this car
this is it because
that car looks like it was rescued by a
car
activist who pulled it that was about to
get put down
yeah it was rescued rescued these cars
were car rescuers
yeah it's wheels it works and you know
but the protests were up on the upper
west side they were protesting around
the uh
the the memorial statue for the soldiers
up there
and i could hear the v's voice like
she's down for the cause but she's also
like okay guys
what are we doing at this point because
at this point we're going like what are
we like
60 days in protest now yeah it's like
two months we really hope you enjoyed
that episode whatever it was about this
is just a stock thing that we're taping
on to every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it and go to
patreon.comridgeboys where things get
really wild
[Music]
huh